esports are just one thing with the
ability to conjure potent emotions in
all of us
it just so happens that
they're damned good at it that's one
thing i want to say
fighting game is
something
so great
[Music]
damn it why did he have to say that i
know that's you guys don't know that's
what got james the worst it almost got
me too
i won't lie
it might feel like a weird fit when a
fist bump and a shouted nice is the
typical affirmation a player receives
broken leg
[Applause]
but this is competition after all it's
not just about finding out who the best
are and putting them in a numbered
spreadsheet it's about the humans behind
the hoists and highlights and all of us
need to
show example on this tournament for
whole world
we need to stay together as a unit with
our fans with our friends
with everyone who is gonna watch this
tournament so while many esports players
display a cool professionalism or at
least a charming awkwardness
how is it that you're able to play with
so much confidence on the world stage
[Applause]
there are a few players who are
very different they wear their heart on
their sleeve and regularly let their
emotions out for the viewers to see and
perhaps
no one fits that bill better than french
cs veteran dan
apex madisla
apex essentially grew up on a
counter-strike server but despite now
being a wisened veteran of the franchise
his emotional timber is actually one of
the few things about him that hasn't
changed very much astralis can actually
continue to put the pressure on vitality
here
hey thanks man okay i can't repeat what
he said but it's pretty good
a career this long that has taken him to
places that most of us plebs can only
imagine
means adaptation it means changing
yourself from an explosive entry to an
engineering in-game leader to remain
relevant as a past generation disperses
and a new one steps into their place
what it doesn't mean is that you have to
stop doing stuff
like this
[Music]
[Music]
so who is apex really how did he make
the positional swap that let him
continue playing counter-strike at a
high level even as he started
encroaching upon the big 3-0 and why is
it that you can take apex out of french
cs
[Laughter]
fantastic but you can't take the french
cs out of apex what a spray
apex
okay guys so before we dive into apex's
story i've gotta do the thing where i
ask you to please like subscribe and
turn on notifications we are excitingly
close to two million subs and
you could be the one
to help us get there okay so if you're
not familiar with dan madislar there's a
bit of history you should know and for
that we need to go all the way back to
2012. a year when people were obsessed
with korean dance moves stuntmen were
leaping from outer space and
counter-strike would change forever you
see before the release of global
offensive the french counter-strike
scene was largely playing source which
to some was the illegitimate heir to
1.6's throne and that was where france's
early stars in the next game would be
born they were one of the strongest
regions in the world and their final
form very games was a veritable who's
who of french aiming prowess that
included apex who had earned his
competitive chops as an entry fragger
but not just any kind of entry you see
apex was the kind of entry who
frankly
liked to go hard rpk takes on smith
scream takes down one on the rpk apex
answers back he took him down getting
the second one on to uzi that's two
headshots in a row
apex with some amazing aim shakti takes
down nbk apex six on horse so skipping
forward here apex
that deagle takes down smiz
fairy games picking up the pistol round
on ct side existence takes on the
screams horse sits down hard to get the
headshot exists and apex oh he effects
with two more with the deagle apex
pushing his way onto the cat trying to
make sure they don't take it exists and
takes on one apex gets two more one on
the screen and horks and existence
finishes it off it's gonna make it four
to three now in favor of very games so
making a bit of a comeback early on
though
nexus a deco apex takes not two and a
horse and scream smith gets dropped by
nbk kenneth takes out shocks and a
grenade the release of cs go brought
together both 1.6 and sorcerers and the
french were no exception while apex
didn't make it onto the inaugural fairy
games roster for go his wild unmitigated
aggression made him an absolute staple
of the french scene apex inside here
gonna pick up an easy double triple all
headshots going for another one and he's
gonna get it and it's actually gonna be
the ace from apex and when they peeked
out one by one by one before the bomb
was even being planted it gave nip the
opportunity to
kill them all it looks like nip here
just clearing everything slow and
methodically but they're actually taking
a lot of casualties it's apex who just
delivers a phenomenal hat trick
dispatching of three nip players he's
all on his lonesome but now he has but
one player left to find and now exist
will run over get it and he will be
spotted and it will be apex to win the
round single-handedly for ldlc uh it's
still causing a bit of a nuisance apex
he's on site here but he's gonna get
surrounded by three gets two in a row oh
my word
that is absolutely brilliant from apex
but he's always been a grinder a guy
trying to spend as much time in the
server as possible and he's always drawn
admiration for his willingness to do
whatever it takes to get the team
motivated and moving
baby don't hurt me
don't hurt me
no more
what is love baby don't hurt me in a way
that was a skill forged in the fires of
french cs
and well it's volatility it's common
knowledge that as the region's fortunes
rose and fell the rosters of french orgs
often shuffled in an attempt to try out
new configurations and perhaps luck into
that one major winning combination these
constant shuffles meant that there was a
[ __ ] minefield of interpersonal
problems that crept up over the years
and when the dust finally settled and a
roster was finalized there were certain
kinds of players that seldom made
sacrifices in terms of role for example
opers traditionally got to op and
rosters were often completely built
around a specific igl's vision of a
french lineup so for better or for worse
it was usually the other three guys on
the team making sacrifices in terms of
positional preference
if the lineup had an all-star rifler
they usually got a pass to but not
everyone can be shocks or kenny s and
this is how you got the other but still
critical pieces of french rosters that
remain underrated even today think nbk
rpk happy and kiyoshima guys who pretty
much did the dirty work from the shadows
and who were necessary for the team to
win
apex who was neither an opera nor an igl
was no exception and while apex did miss
out on the first major that france won
he was a part of the region's second
roster to do so in 2015. he's gonna be
stuck in this position and there is one
player that's going to challenge him as
the t's spill into the bomb site it's
gonna be apex with the five seven and
happy from the back to pick up frags
it's looking quite good here for envious
multiple kills coming in apex there from
forklift doing a massive amount of
damage
yes he will get the final kill with the
wall bang apex phenomenal performance
with that pistol so as long as you don't
get head shot you're probably going to
win that fight and already guardian
boosted up looking for that headshot and
it's apex who lands it first
there's your starting tone and we go for
the pop flash gonna drop as well they're
hunting for flame and apex has been
unleashed two kills for him to start
things off but edward is doing work as
well apex a third kill for him and he's
on the way to the ace if he can get it
again he gets a quad and now he's just
gonna be down to seized what got into
apex during that break what have they
told this guy and it was that very same
year that fans began to take notice of
just how animated of a character apex
was which really came to the fore with
this now iconic image of him becoming
one of the community's most recognizable
memes apex is one of those guys that the
camera ops the producers they know they
can cut to him when something crazy
happens and they're gonna get a great
reaction
and that's something you can't say for
every pro apex brings the emotional
impact of rounds to a whole other level
and it's one of the things that i think
has really earned him fans over time
it's an added dimension that i think a
lot of people underestimate the
personality factor of the player
makes
eu better than na
what what do you think
makes europe better than north america
well it's uh
i think it's mainly because of the t
sides
yeah i don't know but mainly when i see
cloud9 i'm like
what the [ __ ] are they doing it's too
slow it's too
i don't know it's
it's too easy to play i guess well it
was really hard game because we lost the
first map 162 which is like a
i don't know how to say but it's like we
got
so
yeah
i had to say that you have two players
there who need to get by and obviously
the presents and that is extremely
i love it i want us to go through and to
go to to the playoffs that's all my wish
right now so yeah focus on the third map
and
i just want to
wreck this brazilian that's that's uh
uh sorry v for victor is one thing but
he doesn't really care who's on the
opposing end there he wants the
brazilians he wants the australians he
wants them all chad we're quite far away
from uh brazil so we're in the southern
hemisphere
i get the point i get the point as the
french shuffles continued into 2017
apex found himself as part of a long
fabled french super team g2 esports and
let me tell you they hit the ground
running i want you to see they're making
their way towards b
in force
he got by chris jake gets the first one
they should punish him right now and if
they are they do
low on hp as the terrorists come
streaming
in rushing it towards the site it's apex
doing the damage gonna get himself two
dennis does get one in return looking to
try and close the gap that much more
he's on three frags
apex
the man
with a plan in this pistol
dennis pulling on back stuck between a
rock and a hard place will go down as
apex picks up for nbk
dispatching of oscar and there is the
start that g2 wanted as is going to be
on the deagle p250s across the rest of
the team as well a bit of utility to get
something done but we're not really
expecting too much some aggression from
patreon actually might be able to catch
that one kenny has dropped apex trades
and he finally switches back to his
weapon and they're just going to take
that pick with you know
charging to the a site just completely
barreling their way in as another one
comes through for apex to find snacks as
well and bialy will be dropped this man
is just on fire three kills and two will
remain only one more left on the side
but he should be aware that neo is in
his back corner in a second
you know still alive and kick it finally
gonna go down at the hand of apex he's
looking to try and get another ace and
it's well and truly on the cards there
we go the man himself so they will move
in but they're gonna have to be cautious
of mid
as automatic
pushes himself in his east it's a good
nade though as you keep mine a lot of
these players don't necessarily have
armor but nothing swinging back out now
arm with the ak gets a kill apex able to
trade onto two and now it falls down to
this mid player moving back in
automatically back downstairs but apex
able to save it the thing is these early
honeymoon phase successes were nothing
new to freshly formed french rosters and
neither were the dramatic eventual
inevitable declines and as the g2
experiment eventually moved on to new
players following an extremely french cs
breakup it called into question the
future of both the region and the
players who'd failed to propel it
forward in the wake of g2's roster
implosion in 2018 apex went looking for
a change and he found it on vitality the
first major factor was of course
xaiwu the most explosive french opera to
emerge since kenny s but the team also
seemed open to doing things a bit
differently even though the roster was
mostly french uk igl alex was added as
the team's leader months after the
initial roster was signed though alex
eventually left it gave apex an
opportunity to try something he'd never
done pick up the reins and become an igl
negative
now for a balls to the wall bruiser like
apex
this was a big change but it's what
needed to happen if his region was going
to get some much needed direction energy
and firepower simple does everything
within his power catching that shot onto
rpk you'd think he'd done enough apex
plays it to perfection though that
palace after plan it wasn't even a
palace plan oh no
jesus dan he must live back here to buy
the time and a nice flick take down
convict shark sister what a spray and
it's a triple to end it
but now zai wu now the final boss is
here and you're not gonna get past him
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i love apex so much but things were
about to change even more because
vitality's roster essentially the last
french cs lineup that could truly be
considered tier 1
was going international while the team
was far from terrible 2021 was just
extremely inconsistent for a roster with
the most explosive and exciting prodigy
the esport had seen in years
top eight at a major just wasn't enough
so they went north to find even more
firepower adding danish destroyers
magisk dupree and coach sonic vitality
was now an unholy alliance between
france and denmark and while that had
obvious advantages the so-called
astrology roster had some challenges
that apex had to address as well
firstly
well
it was emotional the move was reported
widely long before it actually happened
and the roster had a tight bond
plus it was the last tier 1 french
roster at least for now what happened in
vitality he became an in-game leader he
grew like that and i always talk about
these days you know it's not just the
culture just the in-game they're a duo
right they need to have a good
relationship they need to be on the same
page and i think you can see from the
shots you're seeing now like you know
him and access there's mutual respect
there i think from all of the players
the team's identity was another question
glaive's astralis had a tightly defined
system while apex used his intuition
built over years of competition as a
mid-round wild card so which would
prevail in vitality even communicating
would have to change and they had an
interesting system for that one that
apparently involved pepsi
dictionaries
but the real question is how is apex as
an international igl working out well
they slid in the standings a bit after
the change and there are clearly some
kinks to be worked out but they did
manage to qualify for the antwerp major
and once they got there clapped cheeks
in the challenger stage
oh oh my god no
no
stack perfect read smoke headshot how
did he hit it
he wasn't even scoped it barely looked
like it and of course i remoted kills on
bench with a famous in fact he's a b
could come as a bit of a surprise right
now fours
he might have been the first man to fall
in the last couple of rounds but there
he delivers with the eagle
oh my goodness and apex can't believe it
that that's how the round starts in the
span of a 13-year playing career apex
has evolved from being a fearsome french
entry fragger into a general that his
comrades are willing to follow into
battle without hesitation but in spite
of the fact that he's matured into the
closest thing france has to a tier 1 igl
fans can rest assured that regardless of
the level of responsibility that falls
on his shoulders he'll never stop being
the same old apex we do have apex with
us so material you're gonna be able to
ask him a couple of questions hello apex
congratulations
hello thank you i just wanna ask pimp
how many tournaments one is it's really
important for me
okay thank you
i really just can wish we could sound up
to
i go i go hard in the [ __ ]
paint i really did it's like it's
perfect you know like
you could be the one
to help us get there
yes you that could be the one
you can help us get there all of you
together combined